just across the border from war-torn
syria in a forgotten city is an
unexpected site
the hotel palmyra
this hotel is different than others
because time has washed away the walls
time has left this impact it is it is a
journey into the past
so many people have passed through this
hotel
this hotel has been here since 1874 and
this is why we try to keep it as it is
the city of balboa has changed of course
it's feeling the impact of the war on
one side of the borders but it's also
feeling the effects of economic
depression that's affecting the whole
country
at one point there were no visitors to
speak of and that was very difficult
the hotel used to be a haven for
visitors because of the ancient roman
ruins just outside its doors
it is a constant reminder of me of the
importance of balbic and this is
something that was not accidentally
built here if i wanted to describe the
view in front of me daily when i look
out of the window when i come to the
hotel i'd be speechless and generally
it's hard for me to be speechless
the smell of this hotel is of carpets
old walls and
rusty
faucets but that makes you smile
and this is i think essentially what
memories are all
about the old personnel that has been
here since the 50s and some from the 60s
have stayed with us because to them it's
home
hello
and
and this is the feeling that keeps them
going even with tourism dwindling in
this region
we've never closed the doors of the
hotel
no one has a right to touch hotel
palmyra
except for time
you